hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the theater
now you guys recommended that I play the
updated version of the theater because
the other one wasn't too great but
anyway um this one is update is actually
on the unity engine of all things and
everything should be working a lot
better and also look a lot better so
let's get I actually read the
creepypasta and it was pretty
interesting and though I guess the
ending is just what it is if the
creepypasta is literally a game named a
theater so this is pretty easily
translation into one to the other
ooh hello I want to go home already okay
all right so this one should play more
into the actual creepypasta and should
be a lot better to the dedication of it
I can't look down very much I can only
look at hello you look weird thank you
please enjoy the movie okay yay oh boy
it's gonna be this again okay I'm ready
for anything buddy thank you please and
enjoy the movie just like and enjoy your
mother okay I don't know how to make
things change in this he's enjoy the
movie okay nothing's the same as it was
before
thank you good please enjoy the movie
what's wrong with your face bruh must be
snow that can't be swirly face swirly
voice was in the creepypasta that I read
but he wasn't the Usher thank you
ah please enjoy the movie okay
everything seems to be going hunky-dory
so far nothing strange yet you please
enjoy the movie this may take a while I
mean what guy wonder when this
creepypasta first came to be because
good game itself obviously never exists
Joey then
so the creepypasta must be a recent
adaptation of some other story because
there's a probably a reason why I was
with you in the era it's possibly them
specifically about the doom era of games
and I'm curious to see if there was some
precursor to it but I'm not thank you
please enjoy the movie yeah apparently
that voice is actually mr. creepypasta
who is a youtuber the reads creepypasta
for other people's entertain these enjoy
the movie I guess he got a little rule
he's gone
hooray yay that tired tyrannical movie
usher is now gone which is good I guess
what what uh huh what's going on whoa
what whoa I see something what what's
happening what's happening where am i
where am I it's like really hard to see
but I can see something what whoa wait I
see I see something I'm not sure what
though I it's like really dark I'm still
walking it's like really dark ha ha oh
that's mr. swirly face
hi guys rare oh okay we're back now
nothing happened
nothing strange happened yes I am
markiplier I want all of my fans to
shove giblets into their eyeballs No
thank you please enjoy the movie what do
whoa wait
hey luck this was part of the
creepypasta at some point it was
supposed to replace all of wait what are
you doing way well back up there sunny
gem that's great
okay so swirly face you would hello what
are you doing what are you doing there
we're doing there what no ho thank you
on to brick wall no no
/ refused this is not right okay I guess
this is the end all right
oh god okay all right I guess that's it
that was a much better adaptation of the
app app - Abba Dabba Dabba tation of the
game of the creepypasta than the
previous game so I should have played
that one instead but anyway you live and
learn in the life of a let's player so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation more videos that I've
done dry freeze up links in the
description below and as always I will
see you in the next video
ah
bud
Oh
the